hopefully you've all seen the first
video to this
if not then spoilers I guess unless you
already yeah what's going on
I'm gonna go back down into the subway
back down to the Train and save all the
people so that's the plan anyway
welcome back let's carry on play in the
game
nice job super comfy I'm impressed back
in business
yeah mostly but we need 30 to 40 minutes
to finish maintenance Nikolai how are we
doing dogs brawling with us that's the
one that killed the other chicks
fighting with us
why is she here she told me get the
trains when we get that time to start
getting did we fit she's unreliable
again pull the trigger when it counts
hey take it easy she'll get you killed
sorry about that everyone's a little
worked up is that mrs. right just please
give it and then I huh I remember to
talk it out to judge it go on
oh I can okay wait I've got my staff I
want my little gun
[ __ ] wasted it [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] might work okay where is he
I might die a few times here
Oh
I want to trick him to go into the red
barrels did he even come into the broom
anything he came into the room okay I
don't know I could like play with him
and then get him to go to the red
barrels
Carlos do you copy Carlos
so we can't go in here can did I pick I
did pick up that map of the area
perfect the first sites were yes oh good
it's good yeah
okay so let's put this one away keep
that for me
Oh apparently I did Steiger nemesis oh
good so my grenade did actually get him
I didn't think it got him because he
hadn't opened the door but I guess
that's why he never came into that room
with us because uh Isis tagged with him
EEE how do I get through that I'm gonna
get into that how do we get over there
well there's a door is that door
can I get in here
break the glass come on no new breakfast
shooted
I was virtually talking to my friend the
other day about wasn't evil and he was
like have you got system as yet I like
to as a music oh oh dog and lychee right
now oh this is exactly so we're gonna
end up back in the LAPD right because
this is exactly where everywhere when we
word Leon I want to go down there
disgusting
can't get that ladder
[Music]
we've been receiving reports of an
authorized personnel and the control
areas of the facility in response we're
replacing the aging mechanic called
locks and implementing new security
protocols unlocking the new electric
locks requires a special may battery
pack to be distributed to all employees
please keep your personnel battery pack
on hand okay so probably find a dead
person with a battery pack so I'm gonna
have to jump down here that's gonna be
nice
oh sweet looks so cool I'm definitely
get up there or I can carry on it's
probably something down here if I carry
on [ __ ]
but why should I go
Oh smell that way no that way
[ __ ] it Oh
what the hell was that he didn't follow
me at least big sewer worm thing
I'll open it Wow you tell him you have
to go down with the sewer worm thing
no Wesker says that they've skipped like
80% of the original content for Resident
Evil 3 that's not good what's the point
oh my god what the hell
cereza shoppin
I feel like we have the upper hand here
maybe we'll just go this way yeah well
just good this way
oh [ __ ] Wow
oh my god Oh
whoa [ __ ] damn well that was a that was
pretty brutal woman okay so what do I
have to do with those things so I just
have to dodge out of the way of them and
then get them when their mouths open I
guess
okay so I know if I go in here
he's gonna come out of the left and then
I can run away
open up your [ __ ] mouth mates
open it up
oh my god let me reload yes my housemate
must be like why she do just like oh
cool cool now we know how to defeat
those a hand-grenade wants to kill them
that's good to know we've got one how
many of these bullets closer to bad it
takes four shots to kill them
I will save the save the shotgun I'm
sure it will be much more beneficial
than this old nothing oh we can see oh
we got explosive yeah what is what is
this day what does that do this is gonna
help us you can just put a grenade right
in their mouth when they open it it's
gonna be good
gonna be good thanks guys thanks for the
support I can see in chat calling me a
zoo exterminator yes that is me there's
my new title invoice from gun shops
kendo thank you for purchasing the
grenade launcher we've made special
adjustments to this piece to ensure
compatibility with a variety of
ammunition types for optimal performance
be sure to choose the right ammo for the
right situation as we discussed at the
time of purchase this is a refurbished
model and the chamber needs to be
manually cycle between shots
oh that's annoying so is it like one
shot at time and then I guess I'll take
an extra moment but this is reflected in
the price as agreed explicit Brown's
explosive a times cheers for
surveillance is supposed to eggs perspi
acid the flame Browns and acid Browns so
I am Oh are we gonna go back in to see
those like plant zombies again because
if so then that'll be where our is the
acid rounds or flame rounds are needed
cat member then such a long time since
you've played President Evo - feels like
forever ago yeah
March the fourth gammas release from
time for the first time movements
sluggish combat potential learn
experimented with additional core modes
and drugs one adjustment for positive
results with a significant rise in
combat potential
specimen is not able to move quickly and
swallow prey whole
yes so these are how they were made
umbrella has officially shut down gamma
research we managed to smuggle some
specimens with especially high potential
in the lab before disposal dr. Logan
Carlyle is more committed than ever to
perfecting the gamma line two weeks
since relocating to the sewers increased
temperatures have led to a decrease in
water quality but specimens appear fine
despite my concerns
gammas quickly learned the lair of the
sewers and within two days we're
exploring the entire underground of
Raccoon see this is so creepy why did
you let them do this all specimens are
familiar with and friendly towards us
really friendly what are you are you
sure Michal [ __ ] I called [ __ ]
all specimens up yeah yeah yeah we just
for that I have procured high-powered
weaponry as a safeguard in the event
that they become uncontrollable we were
lucky to secure this place by bribing
the sewage department chief
but it's beginning to feel cramped due
to the gammas continued growth okay so
maybe they were like babies like maybe
maybe this is like a gremlin situation
they were look super cute and now
they've grown into these massive
unmanageable terrifying things also
thanks for following gooey and five five
tears a water treatment worker found his
way into the lab but the gammas promptly
an element in limine tipped them this
proves their viability fulfil G's always
reach out to Ambrose European branch
tomorrow perhaps they'll see the light
no the too dangerous you should not be
I need this and my shortcuts what do I
have my shortcuts right now I've got my
knife and make a grenade was wrong to
replace oh I hate this I hate decisions
well override the knife but we need to
get more of these anyway because we've
got explosive b-but we need another
explicit B right right I feel like I
should put more stuff away but I'm not
quite sure what maybe I'll put this way
for now well notice if we find another
one I can make some more ammo I don't
want to put this away because we're not
done with them you might find something
else it's locked
I'll put our winter now so I can pick up
more stuff
okay let's see how good this one is
please tell me that's not - that does
have to bright or do I have nothing I
think I have nothing
oh well I'll chuck this when I am where
is he
no he's here somewhere there is
hey birdie hey pal come on come on over
here
[Applause]
did I get in I got him yeah that's good
yeah I think I might have two rounds
here I don't know that's like how many
it can hold and how many I do have or
how many I do have and how many have
after that does that make sense I don't
waste them either thing about team
what's right here ah good I do have to
and show have any more after that
you die good boy good boy
playground
[Music]
there we go
now do we have everything here we don't
there's stuff that we haven't picked up
guys
I'm gonna fix up
Oh secrets behind the waterfall
is he gonna get out
no there's a book here I think this
person was like hiding this is cool
I like this
it happened again they got Caine this
time I saw it all one of those things
just swallowed him whole head to toe I
tried to warn them when girl went
missing two weeks back the cop says he
probably skipped town but I said no way
not with this baby coming any day they
listens nope
this is [ __ ] [ __ ] puking [ __ ]
feet breath toad face [ __ ]
every time I think I've lost them
another one pops out of the tunnels and
it's not like I can count on the [ __ ]
cops don't trust those pencil pushers at
HQ either next time one of those freak
shows its face I'm gonna hit it right in
his big ugly mouth yeah I wish I wish I
like read this before I got eaten by one
but hey we can go
yeah
where are we
laughs we got a battery pack we can open
doors now oh we have foul follow items
[Music]
there we go can we combine this with
this sweet yep we got ourselves a
brunette
I love lesser my little darlings it's
already been three months since we fled
here together I find myself thinking
back to the day you hatched is this a
love letter to the to the sewer
creatures your little voices maybe
tremble with pride your adorable little
Bali's brimming with incredible
destructive power and of course that
Verret voracious insatiable appetite you
are no less than the pinnacle of the
Hunter series and yet they ordered me to
destroy you
they said you were unfit to use as
weapons because of a few minor
vulnerabilities so what if you are
susceptible to heat thanks for the tip
so what if your delicate mandibles are
exposed when you feed haven't they ever
heard of character flaws it says very
flaws that make you so very very
precious to me but we'll show them yet
down here we'll continue to walk this
evolutionary path together we'll prove
to umbrella that you my beloved hunter
garments are truly superior I love this
build details but resently will put into
the game they're so funny she's really
freaking love letter to the Beasties
each to their own I guess
[ __ ] new actually kept it okay we'll
come back here another time then I guess
where am I going oh yeah
don't say they come back again I will
hate it if they come back yen
oh [ __ ] they come back again
thank thank thank you thank you thank
you Sean
[Music]
I want to go and get my skates go back
down here just in case there's another
one
I want to go and get my pick I'm sad
okay no we'll just go I instinctively
just started running back as soon as it
filled the opening right so what we're
doing this way want to get my lockpick
and go back there and see what's there I
don't want to get rid of a gun and I
guess this one's kind of redundant at
the moment okay
listen here then now we're gonna go back
to the safe we'll go back to the other
safe room because that's on our way
anyway is it no it's not because we've
got to go up the
who is uh we slid down the waterfall
from the other things in the way so I
think we do have to go back here I'll
make some more ammunition with this also
done and then we're ready let's get this
one out
still not done with that one yeah Dean
being Dean okay well stall this one
let's make these freakin combined there
on that one man what kind of gun part
you're just never gonna powder how I
really want to get some or pocket spaces
actually annoy me okay
we have sort out our inventory you know
we can carry on playing the game let's
do this
I didn't expect that one to happen
by
hey Colin Williams take IO
I hate that it takes up to all spaces
wait do we not take it back afterwards
Oh
so we can only open one door where then
we have to keep it in there that's a
bull
but yes you must have a Miss that would
be so imperious you're like we should be
saving the mo for that one nice so maybe
new choice shotgun next time
[Music]
power source
Oh lol Oh perfect
okay let me just look around a bit
right
Oh
okay wait wasn't there another locked
door around here maybe this is how we
can get that pouch I want to get the
pouch
wait I don't want to go too far because
I wanted the pouch this is not going the
way of the pouch the way of the pouch it
was the opposite direction
she's like a bag I feel like I should be
going back Carlos yeah I mean I need to
go back let's check that last door yeah
I'm alive
I lost him I see you I see you yeah
pesky you don't even make any noise how
am I supposed to know you there oh now
you are yeah now that I'm back right I'm
just gonna go check the other door I
hate feeling like I've left bit hours
what doors are they need to open this
one
the pooch what are you guys talking
about the way of the pooch what I knew
there was a reason why I was turning
around
yeah the pooch yes now give me my safe
back so I can take out my end my log
pick please oh yes cool cool cool this
is good I'm glad we went in this room
she could grab more stuff yeah I'm gonna
grab my stuff
lockpick certainly got two free spaces
but oh well okay we'll get one more of
these and then some of this guy oh yeah
but I guess we're pretty we're living
this in here for a while so
I need to keep turning around now just
see if there's a little pesky bubble
heads are there
oh my god
he just stops
don't try to get us cuz we reach the
cutscene point no but you can use
weapons uh-uh honey it's a saver
[Music]
yawns how do I so if I'm using this how
do I change Oh a perfect let's blow this
[ __ ] up
I can't see him
we're doing creepy foolish you just
crouched looking in Oh
he's not out of here
okay
on my way on my way
yawns I love my chakra
[Music]
[Music]
just that stars moment dude sooo not
cool
where is he tonight serious
so nonchalant about it
[Music]
jump jump for your life
oh my god like it I'm just like if I was
there but like why the [ __ ] am I going
up like this whole place is gonna bring
down and I'm going up
nada
whereas where is he oh it's a safe room
in the burning mess of everything we can
just stay here forever and know that
we'll be safe that's nice I think
imagine if he just comes here now that
would be so terrifying
I would not imagine that oh it's a
demolition day well this would be a good
cover-up wouldn't it make him see stars
Jags Wow at the moment Nikki arm is
rolling away from him by the way
everyone if you saw the image that I
shared of the resident evil 3 with with
me as Jill that was Nikki garbs that did
that picture really really talented so
tell them how great the picture was if
you know which one I'm talking about
I shared it on Instagram and Twitter
anyway we have decided to delay the
barnaby office building demolition in
response to ongoing public unrest the
safety reasons all know that school
equipment including generators have been
moved to the roof for safekeeping
how am I going to get out of here or at
least just down nemetes for a little bit
empty to the premises
until the current unrest has subsided
all employees are to stay at home and
await further instructions oh well I'm
when wondering that did she save me
every like two minutes
I guess good
okay let's do this no [ __ ] you sir why
are you still okay
I just through
how are you still okay you know okay
good
oh okay I know I did yeah
like this so on base hours of me king
nice oh [ __ ]
judge dodge done [ __ ] I can't even
[ __ ] see me shotgun to the face
honor honor
oh my bro
Oh oh I'm fine I'm fine all is fine
so [ __ ] hot what am I gonna like what
pays off you done
I'm a lucky duck okay oh my god is
coming cooking escape in I need to get
more with that generator I don't know
why I'm like holding my nose together
like her okay we got this
creature
defeats the creek Shack
come on come on my love
over here
come on come on darling
am I using this shitty-ass gun where did
you go
ah [ __ ] he dodged
but button
[Music]
how the [ __ ] can you doing this [ __ ] no
no all right
Jill Jill Jill Jill Jill Jill Jill
Joe Joe Joe okay I'm showing your name
Oh I'll be okay for one more hair thing
can I reload them from in here cuz
that'd be really nice
ready go putting up when you come on
come on Joe
we love
reload
am I supposed to be aiming for
[ __ ] this [ __ ]
today
oh my gosh that was close well done till
we're all very proud of the army guys we
did it
yeah Wescoe well Jill yeah you know
looking so good
oh dear oh dear um
still only on caution right we we have
to be very careful with this gun you're
like because we need it and we just used
most of the rounds Oh at least Akash
turn our hands this makes me very happy
cool so where are we now where are we
drop down to
Carlos it's Jill do you read me yeah
bastards dead yeah but I wasn't a bad
ass I did what I had to so what does
that say wad
oh thanks for the Lola bridge there
firetruck that's pretty cool pretty
nifty
if I shoot here will they come towards
the shop
hmm okay it's all uses more as a vantage
point I guess
the transit area where are they they're
on a cafeteria Westside cafeteria right
okay
Oh in the restaurant
maybe
if we just stay out that way they'll go
to see this man damn it
hey girl she's watching us oh damn it I
took out that lockpick
oh sweet wait oh I guess I could use one
of my halves I mean I have many okay
Kendu
you're alright yeah alright to stretch
sorry okay little jumpy there didn't
know quite what to expect
no [ __ ] look we're using the subway to
get people out of town you win please
don't say I have to leave this area
because I didn't pick up the thing for
my gun that's good thinking
when we get out there's gonna be a lot
to do you can use a man of your skill
set
what's wrong nothing just uh just bad
timing is all look don't worry about me
I'm gonna make other arrangements okay
you better depress the gun Smith around
no no don't do anything stupid
oh that's that's your job right take
care Jill my prayers have been answered
hell yes so we started we have hungry
however now we've got quite a few so
yeah I probably should have seen that
before
I don't know if I'm just remembering it
from Resident Evil 3 like the original
um but his daughters infected right
pretty sure and that's who is going back
for
it's all right pumpkin it's all right
see that's a good girl
Oh Leon and ADA mat him that's probably
why I'm remembering it that's pretty
cool though we get to see these guys at
different times so what happened when we
met them with Leon was that when the
girl actually was a Zambian had turned
pretty sure it was I'm not going to do
that right there's stuff out here that
we're definitely missing quite a lot
actually
oh is that or is that what that keys for
oh it is
[Music]
he's got twitchy hands I saw your twitch
in your hands
acting like you dead but yeah your hands
don't lie though those hands don't lie
ooh freedom you yes eat these ones open
up your [ __ ] eyeball and comment
what's this mean to get some more
shotgun shells
these things keep turning up
okay let me just check out stairs oh I'm
glad we kept this log pick racoon Times
readers column
dear Editor I'm writing to you because
I'm troubled deeply troubled anyone
who's been a parent knows that crystal
prominent dominate is the place to take
your kids for a trip downtown on
Saturdays and there's no store more
popular or harder on a parents wallet
then toy uncle however I've noticed that
on windy days the big statue above the
entrance wobbles like the only thing
holding it up as a cover of screws is
that the one like the big head that we
saw the beginning in the game if this
such as head tumbles loose on a busy day
children will be badly hurt I've
complained to the manager three times
now but he just isn't willing to rectify
the situation are we supposed to wait
for a terrible accident to happen before
taking action know if heads are going to
roll then let it be the managers take
the deathtrap down can we can we shoot
the head off because that would be
freaking awesome
I think we can this parent was prepared
let's
[Music]
where is that thing anyway I'm sure
we'll get there eventually back that way
[ __ ] this [ __ ]
oh okay [ __ ] it [ __ ] it [ __ ] it [ __ ] it
[ __ ] it [ __ ] it [ __ ] it
[Music]
as I get in I don't think so I was
trying
Carlos sent somebody asking he's
undestructable
hold up
oh my god
please get some more herbs now I need to
find a safe point oh there's the head
thank you
with fine but she's still stumbling
because it makes sense with the the
plotline you know
the head the head right to you okay
I know no one's that but you know
one two two head oh thank you in the
head I wanted to shoot the head oh my
god
wait what the [ __ ]
my hands 1/2 the ready I wasn't on the
keyboards give me a bit of time please I
was reacting to the head falling off
Jesus
minute
- good
areas is the big boy
[Music]
oh dude where am I going
I don't know what to do Everywhere's and
fire
it's actually kind of annoying
unless you're supposed to just go back
to where I came okay fine I'll bite I'll
bite
[ __ ] me
for real why don't you see that one
ah
[ __ ] sake
how the [ __ ] what am I supposed to be
doing
[ __ ] you mr. star and space and pick it
up
awesome
why don't I go
oh this way oh sweet you know what I'm
pretty proud of myself up I managed to
hold up against in pretty town well and
I got another case hell yeah
although I wasted a lot of my ammunition
okay
yeah three cases from nemesis now whoa
let's see what he gave us oh my god oh
is that eight I guess we got everything
good from him but I mean we can do
without it'll help us when we're back in
the sewers yeah I need to I need to find
a green hub dude dude do you have any
haps
but that's shaggy hair though
Thanks hey he saved my ass first
hello Bob braver than me wait
well what matters is that we can get
everyone out of the city now yeah you'll
be safe
well hold up I'm gonna get my hips I'm
glad we can actually go up here the game
hasn't blocked off thank you I'm gonna
take out too
oh I can discarded this one now yeah mmm
asking directly for drugs she needed
them sis doing what's best for Joe
what about you I'm from the south of it
I won't be catching the train
why not now there be new orders
his hair I can never cover every time I
see one I want to know what he looked
like in the original game the Butler of
the Dead some hunt hands is the butler
of the Dead Sophia
confide in me so I'm just waiting the
advertisements oh this guy again
good work your reputation is
well-deserved get inside the subways
about to leave Carlos Tyrell you have
your orders you need to go back out into
the city and find that Daniel part this
isn't the last fight out of town right
do not worry once the civilians are safe
that train will be back it's all right
you go on ahead
I'm not gonna die on you leave you in a
cold cruel Carlos this world okay
you'll need to find a scientist it's
vaccine the research could save us all
you see you're learning killing life
that knitters good luck
let's go
we'll see him again I'm sure
you don't really think Vincent portion
of like part of life
I haven't done to authority by
you will read about teammates
there is something else
funny a brainless somedays can ambush
you look dude like that funny the gate
No
there's a bomb that's a lie what are you
doing it's not that
yeah
shit's bad see he was quite nice hmm
so there are factions of umbrella who
mean well and are necessarily fully
aware of the actions got to be clear
this city by now along with your hot
date no she's not like that
you literally just met her you didn't
even know what her name was
all right you sure it looks like a
cemetery to me light bouncing off my
hair I'll get over this eventually it
just looks so good but it's so cool wait
anyway looking on their little
individual bits that move on their own
when he moves oh yeah what kind of guns
do we have some trifle
[Music]
not quite a shotgun but I guess he'll do
all right stop see Wow oh that's their
interesting so that's how he got there
shit's locked you stay on the door I got
this [ __ ]
come get so
oh my god take somebody [ __ ] bullet
would he have on him an ID card Alpha
Team rear security that could be useful
let's go chat to our new friend where'd
that cop go don't know don't care
we got a job to do our Intel still worth
a damn than bards in the Starz office
let's find him and take him into custody
custody I thought this was a rescue take
a look at this I've located the stars
office
Carlos yeah yeah yeah I'm just looking
around just give me a moment Jesus
Christ okay remember Bart had access to
umbrellas darkest secrets he knows we'll
try to keep him under our thumbs so this
search and rescue mission is really more
like fine to detain right good to know
hey Carl open the shutter so you can get
through you stay here and find out
what's been going on here this is mine
to call you if I find anything
Thanks
be careful yeah you too if Carlos did a
better job of cleaning up this place
Leon Claire wouldn't have such a hard
time in here wait
yeah wait does that mean that nemesis
was walking around at the same time as
mr. X but nemesis is like so much more
advanced than mr. X interesting well I'm
glad we didn't at least have to deal
with them both at the same time that
would be annoying
Oh ID card for the ID card work from now
on the same card will be required to act
as storage boxes yes so hopefully in
this one will work okay so I remember
when I look was looking at reviews
people were saying that it felt like
this game we used way too much for was
equal to because it was like
environments but also jump scares
[Music]
oh cool like okay so that guy was there
wasn't you were too but you just got to
see how he got there that's [ __ ] cool
that okay just carry on I might I might
turn around and say no actually it's
pretty boring but right now I think it's
pretty damn cool how we get to see all
of the people that we got used to seeing
pose in a certain way and how they got
there
never again didn't stick around
let me just get some boards
here we go
okay
don't you [ __ ] run at me three shots
[ __ ] this is why I liked playing on the
PC no the PC on them with the controller
total the [ __ ] liquors because you
can actually sleep when you have a
controller and you can't sneak when
you're playing on a keyboard well hey
hey hey I remember you did you manage to
get your snacks out of the M out of the
vending machine yeah cuz he was the one
on the bed wishing why her is there
another one like that on the vending
machine
yeah I think so well the TV's are still
on wait is that gun yeah
come on [ __ ] give me the [ __ ]
she just gonna walk away yeah nice see
ya
t you copycat there's something real gas
down here I don't know what it is
[Music]
oh he said okay good
[ __ ] her now that was a lot of zombies
see lecture stands in two words as much
in this king as investment evil - I
swear was so much easier thank you
although I feel like I should just
really have more ammo years you crawl
around down there what we get such
creepy noises thank you good
I remember there being a lot of zombies
in here suspect was seen behaving
suspiciously what can I speak suspect
was seen baby suspiciously at 1 4 4 to
Bach Street on September the 18th 1998
suspects person was searched producing a
small explosive 7 a timed detonator from
inside his pocket leading to arrest on
the charges listed above a search of
suspects home found more than 20
additional homemade explosives at
various stages in solution suspect was
extremely agitated and not of sound mind
suspect spoke feverishly when
questioning began and at one point
questioning had to be held it due to a
sudden bout of shrieking from the first
event once questioning was resumed
suspect made the following statements I
didn't do it for me I did it for you why
doesn't anyone understand the cops has
attacked the shadows well I mean it's
true oh we can't open this one
thank you very much
okay let's just open this door oh [ __ ]
we can
hey honey wait I'll let you come over
here come on come get me come on come
get me
anything else over here maybe
Oh next what was this shite I don't know
what that is
okay you know what guys I might actually
leave it here wait stand on I wonder if
we can still develop the photos well we
don't have anything just kill those
things I'd be set
I feel like that's like a reference to
some other game like what's that horror
game where you kill them by kill the
ghosts we're taking pictures of them I
can't remember can't remember of course
you can't open it you need to leave
stuff in there for Claire and Leon you
have is weird how when you play as
Claire Oh Leon whichever one you played
second there's still different stuff in
there for you it's like oh okay cool
but I guess I won't complain
it was nice quite a lot of stuff well
nice and set for next time office flying
1000 915 7 is that wait is that for the
one oh wait is this the one that we're
on now we might as well do this quickly
915 7 9 15 7
there we go you know walk shoot you in
the ass you're annoying 915 seven is it
that way
one two three four five six seven right
see more pockets always love a pooch oh
yeah okay never can you're back
save the game made it yeah so so many
bullets in this thing's crazy yeah
anyway I've loved everything thanks
again for watching I will be upload this
soon and I will see you in the next
stream